let's go out to indianapolis and talk to
luke
luke good afternoon uh how can christy
and i help
hey good afternoon to both of you as
always thank you for
the help you provide yeah yeah what's
going on so yeah so at my church i lead
a group and
we're actually going through fpu and
this past weekend we're talking about
baby step three
three to six weeks and actually tomorrow
three to six months and tomorrow
uh we will be debt free tomorrow we're
paying off revenue congratulations
you're excited right oh yeah
my big question my wife and i uh other
people in the group have the same
question
three versus six months so we played the
clip in the video you know based on
a single family a single income family
or how reliable commission based
so if i can give you my circumstances i
i'd really appreciate you helping me out
three versus six months
yeah yeah um so i'm retired military
20 years so i have retirement day that's
never going to go away
um i have disability from the military
that's not going to go away okay and i'm
a school teacher
okay school teacher pay of course can go
away my wife she uh we homeschool we
have seven
daughters yeah and i'm watching to play
out the window right now it's amazing a
lot of estrogen
yeah and and so um
while we are a single family income i am
the sole person
at the same time the military and the
disability comes out to about
46 000 a year and my pay for
being a teacher is about 45 000 so it's
kind of funny i get paid more for doing
nothing now than i get paid for teaching
but uh you know but we have seven kids
so
even though some of the income is
reliable you know more kids you you have
more
events could happen that you need to dig
in more expensive that emergency
but the sooner that we can get past baby
step three i mean baby says four five
and six i got a lot of college to start
saving up for these kids yeah yeah
so i i don't want to put a lot of cash
in savings or
money market that's i don't need to yeah
yeah so i'm looking for advice
yeah yeah so luke what's your uh
guaranteed annual income right now
uh if i were to quit or get fired from
teaching my guaranteed income from the
military and
uh disability is 45 46 000. but there's
no
there's no indication that anything's
wrong with the teaching right like
that's been stable up to this point
that's a hypothetical i just want to
clarify this
not only to the hypothetical i finished
my grad degree in educational leadership
i'm
i'm thinking about being a principal
that which would of course come with the
pay raise yeah so that's that's
as far as we know that's a steady stable
job yes yeah okay so if you're going to
combine everything then
um we're looking at 92 or 93 000. yeah
yeah 92 000 yeah so you're good with no
debt
you're perfectly fine with just three
months man yeah i would i would just
jump into and the reason we give people
a range even when you're talking about
finances that is mathematical and
formula based and there are
steps and principles there's always
going to be a range and comfort level
there are going to be some people that
they will not sleep at night unless they
have six months
just because that's their comfort level
even if all the numbers add up fine and
there's other people that are like
i feel pretty good with three months i
want to go ahead and get that money
going into college fund so
the range is really for you to customize
that aspect of it to your
comfort level and so if you and your
wife and have a conversation you feel
good about your steady income and you
feel good at three months and
or three months worth of expenses and
you want to start to put that money
towards colleges because it's a very
valid
reason to want to go ahead and do that
um i think that's totally fine i think
there's just a little bit of room for
customization within that range
absolutely i mean i i totally agree with
christy we want you to choose
um now if you would have called in and
say hey i'm on a commission-based job i
don't have any savings
i still have debt which you don't have
debit until you pay off all your debt
but if you didn't have something stable
and situated
then yeah we may say hey you know go
ahead and get six months because
you're not as stable with your income
but with you you're stable
luke you have good some good income
you're out of debt
yeah set aside three months and going
ahead and jump over to baby steps four
uh through six right now so i would
definitely do that
but thank you so much for for uh doing a
class and
and i before you go like i'm curious uh
throughout your debt-free journey what
was the hardest part of your journey
so i was actually gonna say that for
everyone that's listening and hasn't
taken the plunge
um starting that one thousand dollars
there is a mental
leap that you have to take it's just a
mental game and if you're not willing to
take that you're not all in
and you just go ish well just don't do
it yet wait till next year when you're
ready
so making that first leap and saying
we're in it to win it
um and not going ish the first the first
step
the first step that's right yeah that's
good good advice
good advice for money or anything just
commit
you know what uh i think it's seth godin
has a great quote he says if you wait
until you have
success to commit you'll have neither
you need to commit to this thing whether
it's the baby steps or your business
or whatever you need to commit
and then you'll have success you will
not have success if you halfway tiptoe
ish your way through you'll never have
either so let's stay right there chrissy
let's turn on christy's teaching head
what if someone said okay i want to
commit i know i need to do this but like
what are the first let's say
two things that they need to do to
actually commit
to the process to the journey so you
know one of the things we talk a lot
around here
is action i tell people all the time
it's not the thought that counts
i don't know who came up with that no
one cares what you thought about doing
no one's bragging about what your
husband thought about getting you for
your anniversary
no one's posting on facebook about what
your kids thought about earning on their
report cards it's what you do
that counts but what's interesting is if
you take a tiny baby step literally a
baby step in anything not just financial
baby steps
that's why we broke it down this way if
you take a tiny baby step
it builds your confidence and it fuels
your momentum
to take the second tiny baby step and
the 30 tiny baby step and so on you look
up one day
and you've built the business you've
lost the way you've gotten out of debt
you've done the thing
but it didn't happen overnight it
happened one tiny baby step at a time
but it all
started with taking a step it's that
step that moves it's the first domino
yes then the second is easier the third
is easier you start to get some
adrenaline some endorphins some reward
from your hard work some payoff you cut
off cut up the credit card you lose the
weight you
whatever that thing is you get your
first sale you're like oh my gosh i'm
doing this yes
research shows anthony that the most
motivating thing
to people male female any age does not
matter
the most motivating thing to human
beings from a psychological perspective
is not money it's not rewards it's not
uh
recognition it's seeing progress seeing
the scale to go down seeing the bank
account go up you see progress you want
to do more of that so make some progress
i told you she's teaching y'all